you have such a good relationship with
like steve urkel the character yeah was
there ever like resentment towards this
character that like people see you so
much as urkel were you ever like oh [ __ ]
steve urkel or have you always been like
cool with it it's tough because um hey
i've always gotten mad positivity from
people about it
so
i really can't only react to the way to
the streets
um at the executive level i think there
were definitely some uh you know certain
issues um but i think it really wasn't
about that wasn't about urkel
so i always like to kind of clarify that
with people i think that was just about
tgif
so what's cjm well tgif was the name of
the entire lineup
and there's like how many shows were on
that it was it was us it was step by
step
exactly
and so i just feel like
that was the beginning really of like
being branded
as an actor
and where brands were just kind of
jumping out like crazy like george
clooney used to play basketball with me
all the time and george is a great guy
because they filmed er right next door
to us
but we're so branded differently you
probably couldn't even imagine and other
people like what he played basketball
with george clooney as a kid it was like
yeah
we're right next door to each other is
there a basketball court there or were
you guys just bros enough to go find one
so this was so this was so funny
george was the one who taught me about
about star power
when i first got onto the show
they had um they erected a basketball
set for me in the alleys between two
stages
and that i played on that on that
basketball hoop my entire childhood and
then one day a teamster came over and
asked me if he could move the
um the hoop out into a more common area
that was uh between our set and er's and
i was just he asked me personally i was
like yeah yeah no it's cool man been
there for three years in that one spot
four years
and um
and then um slowly but surely i would
hear people around the lot saying oh
george clooney's basketball coupe oh
over at george clooney's back
and you know george was on his way to
becoming the peacemaker now and and
batman and the superstar and so suddenly
it was like i know that was that was
mine i said it was okay if they moved it
out there yeah
so we had some great we had some great
battles on there but when i but going
back to wrapping up my point though
about that whole like tgif thing was it
was just like you know there was an era
when office hit big right after the
friends era where it was like anything
on network television had to had to have
that like single camera feel
and uh you know multicams and sitcoms
were just not in they weren't cool so
anybody that came from a tgif show
was just thought to be not a serious
enough actor
and we had to get past that phase
and i started doing a lot of dramas as a
matter of fact i was on every show there
was man if you go back and check man i
did castle i did bones i did uh i did
boston legal i was just like i don't
even care what they want me to say man i
just want people to understand acting is
acting it doesn't have anything to do
with sticking people in these mediums
like that's the sitcom guy and this is
the dramatic actor it's like nah as
actors we look at each other and we know
who can go you know it's just about
whether or not you're going to get that
opportunity yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]